American Horror Story has been thrilling and
terrifying audiences since 2011.
Although shooting one of TV's scariest series
can be a living nightmare, there aren't many
scenes that the American Horror Story cast
would take back.
But for some of the actors, things on set
got a little too real.
Usually, when an actor is struggling with
their lines, their main concern is that the
dialogue won't be convincing enough.
But Gabourey Sidibe had a much more chilling
problem in one scene of American Horror Story:
Coven.
In the episode "Go to Hell," Sidibe's character
Queenie chants a Latin phrase that will summon
Papa Legba, the gatekeeper to the spirit world.
Given that Papa Legba is one of the American
Horror Story characters based on real people,
Sidibe was understandably reluctant to disturb
the actual spirit.
According to Sidibe, her concerns turned out
to be well-founded.
In March 2015, during a panel titled "The
Television Academy Presents: An Evening with
the Women of American Horror Story," Sidibe
said that as she was chanting, the light fixture
in the room started shaking, and her back
went out.
When they moved on to shoot a different angle,
the light fixture crashed to the floor.
They resumed shooting, and that's when Sidibe
felt a finger move up her chin to her lip,
which started to swell.
Waiting in the makeup trailer for a medic,
Sidibe and the makeup artist could hear scratching
on the outside, which she described as
"[...] like something was trying to get in."
Sidibe decided the best approach was to pray,
which seemed to work, as it put an end to
the noises.
Once home, Sidibe called her Catholic friend,
who gave her a devil-banishing prayer.
Everything was peaceful until it came time
to shoot the final episode of the Coven season,
which required that the rest of the cast say
the words as well.
When some of the ensemble found themselves
struggling with the Latin, Sidibe reluctantly
agreed to say the lines again.
This time, she felt a finger run from her
forehead to her top lip, which immediately
swelled up again.
"Do not do this at home, you guys."
American Horror Story has treated us to many
terrifying supernatural characters.
But one of the show's most disturbing monsters
was actually a human — albeit one with a
psychotic disposition who did not respond
well to not getting his way.
In American Horror Story: Freak Show, it initially
seems like the most fearsome villains will
be Twisty the Clown, played by John Carroll
Lynch, and Edward Mordrake, played by Wes
Bentley.
And to be fair, you wouldn't want to run into
either of them on a dark night in the woods,
or even a sunny picnic.
But it was the spoiled, "freak"-obsessed Dandy,
played by Finn Wittrock, who really upped
the violence and sadism — and who audiences
most wanted to see get his deserved fate.
Unlike Twisty and Mordrake, Dandy's murders
weren't inspired by vengeance for a lifetime
of abuse.
He killed out of petty vindictiveness and
to feel a sense of power.
Freak Show was Wittrock's debut season of
American Horror Story, and one particular
scene left him so shaken that he almost didn't
want to return.
In 2015, he told Popsugar that the scene that
bothered him the most was when Dandy massacres
most of the remaining cast of the freak show.
"That was actually the one day that I walked
home like, 'Argh I really hate myself and
don't wanna do this.'"
He described his mental state afterward as
"really despondent."
However, Wittrock got over that initial shock.
He's since become a main fixture of the series
and the entire American Horror Story timeline.
Like his season-after-season co-star Sarah
Paulson, Evan Peters has been a mainstay throughout
the American Horror Story anthology since
the very beginning.
In fact, he's embodied some of the darkest
characters the series has ever seen.
On the inaugural season, later subtitled Murder
House, Peters played teenage ghost Tate Langdon,
who committed mass murder in his high school
when he was alive and continued to do terrible
things as a ghost trapped in the titular home.
His characters on seasons 2 through 4 — Kit
Walker, Kyle Spencer, and Jimmy Darling — weren't
exactly Tate-level terrifying, but his character
on season 5, the twisted serial killer James
Patrick March, chilled viewers to their core.
They felt the same about the handful of characters
he played on American Horror Story: Cult,
which was a mix of real-life and fictional
murderers.
By his own admission, Peters has felt uncomfortable
filming a number of scenes for American Horror
Story, and has felt personally affected by
the subject matter at hand.
In a July 2018 interview with GQ, he sha red
that shooting such sinister material is, quote,
"exhausting" to the point where he's questioned
his own identity afterward.
Peters said,
"It's really mentally draining, and you don't
want to go to those places ever in your life.
And so you have to go there for the scenes,
and it ends up integrating it somehow into
your life.
You're in traffic and you find yourself screaming
and you're like, 'What the hell?
This isn't who I am.'"
He added that nude scenes on American Horror
Story have unsettled him as well — particularly
one that happened in season 5.
The actor shared,
"A strange one was when I was Mr. March [in
American Horror Story: Hotel].
I was doing this butterfly razor cutting of
this poor girl.
[...] It was just horrific and weird and sad.
[...] At that point, it was season 5, and
I was more comfortable with the crew, so it's
like, 'Okay, I guess my butt will be out.'
There were some earlier ones that were very
unnerving."
Peters has seemingly taken all the experiences
on the chin and has done his best to separate
the chaos of his professional life from the
calmness of his personal life.
The actor will be back for American Horror
Story season 10, set to premiere sometime
in 2021, so clearly, any scenes he's regretted
haven't kept him from the series that turned
him into a household name.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about American
Horror Story are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.